hi tom hi sarah hi how are you how are
you
i'm good um both of your performances in
this is just outstanding i mean there's
some really dark elements to this movie
but it was
such an enjoyable watch even though
there are some really hard things to
look at um
tom you said that you are so proud of
this movie what made this experience so
special for you
oh loads of things i mean from from the
workload and from from how hard we both
pushed ourselves
and what we achieved i think from the
relationships and the friendships that
we made on set
um the experiences as well i mean like
making this film was crazy i mean the
things that
we had to do and the emotional places we
had to go to
um it was an incredible experience and
one that i look back on
so fondly if i ever watch the film i
kind of look at it and i'm like
i can't believe we actually did that but
then also remembering like
not only remembering what we did on set
but then what we did
afterwards it's like how do you make
that
how do we know how did we have so much
fun and make
one of the hardest films to watch ever
exactly
you know when you have an especially
hard day on set emotionally i can
imagine there are several of those
days what would be something that you
would kind of gravitate towards to put
you back in a happy place or did you
sort of stay in that the whole filming
it kind of be each other wouldn't it
really i mean if we were having
a moment we would kind of lean on each
other and and we'd help each other out
obviously the russos are very good at
creating a very fun
atmosphere on set so you know we were
always able to kind of step away from
the emotion but i think what
for me my most valued ally was sierra
because
we were there together on almost every
day and uh yeah
you know it was like a safety blanket
yeah i also feel like you know
you were the other person on set who
knew exactly
what i was going through and like where
we had to be so it was nice to
to have that you know and know that the
other person there was going to support
you through all of it but also i feel
like the brothers
really prioritized family time i guess i
would call it you know
going out for dinners afterwards ways to
decompress but also keeping a sort of
light tone on set so that we could come
up for a breath of air
you know once we called cut yeah yeah um
you know sierra what is it about
tom you know his character doesn't
always make the best decisions but what
is it about tom that makes him so darn
charming throughout all of this
even during the dark moment yeah sierra
why am i
so darn charming no i think what makes
cherry
the character so charming and so likable
is
tom as a human being like that's that's
what it is
and this is obviously why the brother
brothers brought you on to it because
they're smart and they recognize that
it's like
it's impossible to not like tom you just
have the biggest heart of anyone i've
ever met
not to make it weird via zoom after
it's not weird my heart is beating
um but it's true you're an
extraordinarily kind person and an
absolute blast to be around and i think
that shows on camera and it's why this
this movie works
um tom how physically demanding and
challenging was this role for you
obviously you
lost weight but there were scenes
especially in the car where
i read that you almost broke your nose
there was a quite um
it was the scene in the car where you
were stabbing yourself in your leg was
that the scene
yes that was the scene and i didn't
nearly break my nose
i just banged my it was i just banged
myself
um i remember like it was it's
interesting the russos are so caring
and they're kind of like our older
brothers is the way i would describe our
relationship and i remember them coming
to the to the car window to give me a
note
and i turned around to look at them and
there's blood all down my front and then
both of them like whoa whoa
are you okay i said yeah i'm fine they
said well listen i know you should
probably go see a doctor but
this looks really good so if you
wouldn't mind if you go again i was like
that's fine just roll the cameras let's
go the longer you wait the more blood is
coming out my nose
um so so yeah it was physically
demanding but you know
we're telling the story that represents
millions of people around the world
so we had a responsibility to do justice
to them
so whenever something was hard whenever
something was difficult painful
uncomfortable it felt right because
we could only experience a smidge of
what people go through in the real life
and so whatever we could do to try and
tap into that was incredibly helpful
yeah tom i have to ask i know you've
already said this
toby mcguire andrew garfield are not in
spider-man 3 but is there a chance
you just didn't see a part of the script
they left something out
well it'd have to be a pretty large bit
of the script that they left out i have
read
what seems to be a beginning middle and
an end um
but uh you know it wouldn't surprise me
if they keep things from me because
everyone knows that i can't keep a
secret
um but but no i can say that they are
not in this film
awesome thanks so much um i'm
congratulations on the film it's it's uh
it was really
fantastic to watch thanks so much guys
see you next time
you